[Music]
now the taylor swift's and what more
could we possibly learn about her look
what you made me do music video well
actually a lot starting with her bathtub
bling
we're told that's more than 12 million
dollars worth of real Neil Lane jewels
Taylor sitting in the snake ring appears
to be similar to the one they loaned a
zoe saldana for the 2013 oscars oh and
how did they pull off a zombie taylors
look well it was the same makeup artists
behind Ryan Reynolds Deadpool she's dead
five days to shoot the music video they
started planning in January and shot
less may the not-too Hittle Swift with
these t-shirts well that was a total
surprise I just want you to know that is
the first and only time you're ever
gonna see me in a crop top I had no idea
that's what I was gonna be wearing but
she me - Taylor's backup dancer todrick
Hall told ET on lines Danny direct oh
that Swift came prepared this was her
first major choreographed dancing we've
had a lot of experience Taylor and I
dancing at the club so I knew that she
had what it took but we didn't film it
that many times she just killed it
Tayler pulled out all the original
outfits to recreate her personas shake
it off ballerina the ringmaster from her
red tour even the silver sequined gown
she wore when Kanye stole the mic at the
VMAs the styles are all on display at
the Taylor Swift experience traveling
exhibit I would very much like to be
excluded from this narrative
[Music]
you